all right thank you john
yeah so um thanks for the invite and
allowing me the opportunity to speak to
you all here today
so i'm going to give a talking um
about this generalized mixed volume of a
polynomial system
and the idea of where this comes from is
that oftentimes in in practice uh the
these systems that come to us from
practice and in applications there there
actually there's a lot more inherent
structure
than
we normally would um would see and that
we would we would look at and so what
we're going to do here is give a little
outline of this so give a little
background of this talk
some motivation give a definition for
our generalized mixed volume some
examples and then at the end some open
questions and i hope that you guys all
have some questions for me as well
so first thing that we that we're going
to start off with is this uh this bkk
bound the bear stein kushner ko kowanski
bound and what is this this is
whenever we have some polynomial system
and we have generic coefficients for
everything well we're going to end up
with the same number of
complex solutions for any any choice of
our any random choice of our of our
coefficients and so what this ends up is
that there's this wonderful theorem by
uh by by those by these three wonderful
guys berenstein kovansky and and chris
nerico who who say that hey look this is
really the same thing as the mixed
volume
of um of of a polynomial system in the
the sense of this mixed volume is a in
the sense of this
these these newton polytopes of a of a
polynomial so
we take the if we take some polynomial f
and we look at the convex hole of this
guy this is going to be our
convex body and now we can go ahead and
do all of our wonderful minkowski sums
and then go ahead and find this this
canonical mixed volume so here's
here's our wonderful definition it's
long drawn out
not going to go terribly too much into
detail just
this exists and what we're going to try
to do
as far as what we're really considering
is how this generalizes to this two
polynomials so as far as we're going to
be concerned in this talk is when i when
i talk about mixed volume i'm really
just going to be talking about well for
as far as a the mixed volume of a
polynomial system what's the number of
isolated solutions that we're going to
have for generic coefficients
and we'll see how this can hopefully we
can try to understand how the structure
that we have from these problems that
come from industry and from practice how
we can keep this structure and and
generalize this notion of mixed volume
okay so let's start with a motivating
example so we have a a structured
polynomial system from c into c n
and it's this guy here and so
what's the first thing that we can say
about this guy we have
some nice repeated sub expressions that
occur in this
and if we go ahead and use whatever
favorite uh polynomial continuation
solver that we want we find that we end
up with a root count of two
but if we go ahead and expand this guy
out
and then go ahead and choose generic
coefficients for for
all of our monomial terms here
what ends up happening is that we get a
actual root count of four so our mixed
volume for this system
is actually four but we actually have a
root count of two so we really want to
understand how does this extra structure
play a role
okay
so what do our current methods do our
current methods are just construct a
homotopy
and we just go ahead and we could use
any number of ways to construct a start
system so we start off with some some
start system g of z and we move to f of
z
and the idea is that we can use total
degrees some multi-homogeneous
maybe a linear product or polyhedral
methods so pick your favorite method it
doesn't matter but the downside with all
of these methods
are that they really don't take into
account this extra structure here so
even with polyhedral methods we'll we'll
track or we'll follow
four paths but we still end up with two
extraneous pass so we we still
in some sense we we we're doing some
extra work and we want to try to reduce
this at the very least what we're going
to do is try to understand
what's what's going on here
so this is our
there's a a continuation picture where
we just have our start solutions of our
start system we just choose any you know
you don't have to do euler prediction
choose your favorite predictor method
and then just do multivariate newton and
just follow these homotopy paths
all the way to our the target solutions
of our of our target system
okay and so
what do we mean when we're saying we
want to try to identify structure well
what is this this is really first of all
it's very difficult to know you know
sort of ahead of time
second of all it really just boils down
to some additional algebraic
relationship on our coefficients and
essentially what this means is that our
coefficients vanish on our discriminant
okay
and it's
really difficult to compute the actual
discriminant variety i mean i actually
went ahead and for the are actually
we'll come back to that example for that
uh for that little guy that i that that
i had just that bivariate system
i was i was trying to get the
discriminant and
i mean i stopped it after two hours i
just didn't want to wait longer than
that so it's to me this is difficult
right i mean we couldn't get it right
away and you know so sort of we we know
that there's some extra structure going
on with that particular system and so a
lot of times some these systems that
that come from practice and from
industry they really have this this
identifiable structure and they're
really given to us with this structure
sort of intact so we you know we're
given some problem from industry and we
really say oh hey look we can recognize
that this structure already exists
so as an example we have um
a serial link robot
and the idea is that we have some joints
and we want to we want to know that say
we have um actually what we'll see is
this is just an
example of
a picture with um two links so we have
the i minus one length and the ith link
and the idea is that we have a whole
bunch of different parameters say the
lengths of these links the distance
offset of the joints
some angles associated with the twists
and then some position values for where
our joints are located
and the the idea is that this just
encapsulates at least two of the links
and we can go ahead and generalize this
to six links and if we do so
then we end up with this system a
polynomial uh system of polynomials
where we have some spherical constraints
some uh some twisting uh constraints and
then finally we have some position
constraints
and what's surprising about this guy is
that we actually have a if we choose if
we go ahead and multiply everything out
choose generic coefficients for our for
our system
then we'll end up with 288 isolated
solutions but for a random choice of our
of our parameters these
distances for the links the distance for
the offsets of our joints
and for and for the the options these
these uh these angles for our our twist
angles
then
this this we're going to end up with
only 16 solutions so
really we have a lot of extra structure
that we're we're really missing out when
we're we're looking at this that's sort
of a nice great example that comes from
from practice
okay so let's go back to our motivating
example
and well
i mean we sort of look at this and
what's the first thing that we can say
well the first thing that we can say is
that we have this repeated expression
this x1 plus 1
you know and he's squared but we have
this x1 plus one he he's reoccurring
several times in our in our in our
polynomial system
and what can we do now with this
is that well let's maybe just do a um
create a new variable
and let's just say y one is just x one
plus one
that's all we're doing we're gonna call
this guy a replacement variable
and we're going to replace our
replacement variable every time we see x
one plus one
into our new into our original system
and then introduce a
third equation that
defines this replacement scheme and so
we're gonna call this oh well first of
all this is uh this has
a mixed volume of two we actually go
ahead and choose generic coefficients
for everything
we actually do get our nice isolated uh
the number of isolated solutions is two
which corresponds to the number of
isolated solutions of our original
system
okay
and what we're going to say is that this
process of transforming this this f here
into this f tilde is going to be our
replacement algorithm
so anytime i say replacement or
replacement scheme by this i mean
whatever choice that we have of some sub
expressions and the corresponding
replacement variables
and uh we will take our original system
and replace
the corresponding sub expressions with
the corresponding replacement variable
and then introduce new equations that
define that additional relationship yes
counting a different thing you're not
counting the number of solutions yes yes
so this is this is this is true but
under an appropriate projection so if we
project off of the y's right we get our
original system back and we'll have the
same number
yeah
yeah and because f3 is only linear
right
saying you're counting solutions so that
not
when the variables are zero right i mean
sorry if the pkk bound like only counts
solutions on the torus right yes yes yes
or yes one x y because you have a
constant term here oh i see i see
because of this extra constant term yeah
okay
yeah okay well
nice example why don't you just replace
y1 squared instead of y1
you could have done that
then you get an extra um
uh here you guys you'll you'll end up
with a square here for that guy
so but but but this is okay we'll we'll
get to that here and we'll get to this
this that's a good question good point
we'll get to that here shortly um but an
observation that we want to uh um
point out is that we can take any
polynomial system
and we can rewrite in a new system using
this any type of replacement scheme so
if we have our different sub expressions
that we want to replace
we can rewrite our our system f as f
tilde and say that we have m prime here
is going to be
the some monomial vector in the original
variables and also in the
new replacement variables
and then
b is just some constant
vector and then y is our replacement
variable c is just some coefficient
vector that comes from our original
system the appropriate replacement
values
and m is just now the corresponding
monomials that occur in our replacement
scheme
and so we're going to have two different
types of replacements we're going to end
up with what's called this trivial
replacement
and this trivial replacement is
essentially when we take the original
polynomial system
and just say all right well one
polynomial system we're going to just
replace that entire thing altogether
okay
and
we're going to do that for for both this
so this in our in our example we just we
do it like this these were all the
monomial terms that occurred here are
replacement variables and notice we have
the identity times
some
the replacement variables here
and this is just the coefficient matrix
of our original system here's the
monomial
vector column of our original monomials
that appeared and we just changed this
into this new replacement guy okay now
we have another type of a replacement
scheme that's called this all monomial
replacement so instead of replacing each
polynomial separately we can just say
all right well let's just replace each
of the monomials themselves instead
okay
and well maybe there's a
and the reason i bring these two guys up
is that they're sort of on either of the
two extremes
and maybe there's a better replacement
at least with our original guy our
original motivating example where we
just replace the x1 plus one with with
that y y1
and so what we're going to say our
generalized mixed volume is
is
take our take some replacement scheme
we're going to fix
fix this
this algebraic set here
and now instead of having a being the
appropriate um replacement from our
original system we're going to let a be
generic so we're fixing this guy here
but now we're letting a be generic
and
what ends up happening is that the
trivial replacement corresponds to the
number of isolated roots of f
and it's going to be less than or equal
to our our generalized mixed volume and
the all monomial replacement is actually
going to give us a situation where our
mixed volume is the same as our
generalized mixed volume
so let's look at an example here
let's go ahead and say we well we see we
have x1 minus 2 we have
x2 squared these these guys sort of
appear several times
and we have a mixed volume of 8
and a root count of 4.
and if we choose
x1 minus 2 and x2 squared as our
replacement sub-expression
sub-expressions
and we let
all of our
coefficients be generic
what ends up happening is we get a
generalized mixed volume of four so
we're fixing this guy here this guy is
fixed based off of our particular
replacement scheme but now the
coefficients that occur from our sort of
our original system these guys are are
generic and so
this is this is what we're really saying
is this is really what's going on so by
doing this replacement we're sort of
keeping our structure that we had
and now what we're doing is we're
randomizing our sort of our system that
we've done this replacement on
so let's look at maybe a little bit more
another example
now in this last example notice that
each of these two replacements uh
choices
they're sort of um univariate in in
either of them right so we just have x1
and x2 these guys are separate well
we're not really restricted that we can
go ahead and do a replacement with
multiple guys so
notice that we have this guy this x1
squared minus 2x1 x2 squared plus 3x2
minus 1. he appears several different
times with varying powers
but
we notice now that he's he's bivariate
so we're not we're no longer restricted
to this univariate situation that we saw
in our our previous example and what
we're going to see is that we have a
mixed volume of 48 so if we go ahead and
multiply this all out
choose generic coefficients for
everything we have 48 isolated solutions
and it turns out that for this
particular system we actually have 24
24 solutions
okay so let's let's choose
one particular replacement we're going
to let y y3 be
x1 squared minus 2x1 x2 squared
and just go ahead and replace them
everywhere so notice we didn't do the
entire
replacement of of that one sub
expression that occurred everywhere
and
what we see is that we end up with this
generalized mixed volume of 30. so
this generalized mixed volume is really
dependent on the choice of our
replacement scheme that we've that we've
done
and if we go ahead and uh well we we're
still going to have the same root count
that we had from before the 24.
so if we go ahead and do this do this
again but actually do the replacement
with
the the entire sub-expression that
occurs
we actually do end up with a generalized
mixed volume of of 24.
and so it turns out that if we look at
our our serial link robot
this uh with the the six different links
and six different joints if we choose a
replacement scheme where
this dot product
and these each of these individual cross
product terms we use
choose a replacement scheme where we let
these be our sub expressions that we
replace
we get our generalized mix volume of 16.
okay so this is this is nice because
here we had something where we had some
some really nice structure
and what we've done is
kept a hold of that structure
by fixing some algebraic set in our
replacement scheme and then randomizing
sort of the polynomials that we had
originally okay with the replacements
plugged in right
and so
the nice thing about this is that this
extends to positive dimensional
varieties so we can
we're working on this uh this is joint
work with brent davis and john honstein
and there's a lot more details that are
going on with this i'm happy to discuss
this uh later on i didn't really the the
point of this talk was just sort of an
introduction of this idea
and so so we're we're finishing up this
paper and and this should all be
included
and so
it's just really important to note that
this does actually generalize to this
pot to the positive dimensional case
so some questions before you guys all
bombard me with your own
um some uh first a note is that
if we have more replacement variables
what ends up happening is that we end up
with
a larger system you know that than we
what we started with so maybe our linear
solves that we're using um are going to
be not not as quick
so there's this there's going to be this
trade-off that occurs so what's a good
number of replacement variables that we
can choose to actually go ahead and get
the
um to have like an optimal replacement
scheme
all right
and the second question is
slightly slightly different
um
what's happening is that
if we let our oh all right so so we have
these so so we have this these systems
and we have some additional structure
and what we want to know is is there a
way to to choose the the right now to
construct some type of start system that
has the exact number of homotopy paths
where we we we keep this this this uh
the structure and are able to track it
but we will maybe we don't actually want
to use replacement because this is going
to extend our systems going to make it
make it much larger
and
that there's some really nice results
from
patrice philippon and martin sombra that
look at this in this this torque setting
and so
it's it to me it seems like there ought
to be a way to so so these results that
they have they have this
this sort of formula to be able to give
an exact root count
um
whenever you look at one particular
variable in
in a different coefficient ring
and you look at these sort of viatic
newton polytopes these roof polytopes
and this and this other torque setting
and it ends up that you can sort of
reduce your root count by
removing some extra points out at
infinity and so the idea here is that
maybe
we we ought to be able to use that
information
and maybe do some type of augmented
polyhedral methods to actually have an
exact
number of homotopic paths that we would
want to track for these these structured
polynomial systems
and so with that i'd like to thank you
all and
so uh i know that
maple for instance has a command collect
so you could like give a system of
polynomials and you could say oh i have
this variable y and i want to treat that
as the most important variable and look
at its coefficients and the other
variables
imagine a way that you might get some
way of finding a replacement scheme like
that
but like the general system of
polynomials i hand you uh i mean if i
told you the replacement scheme ahead of
time you might have a chance but how do
you find
any replacement scheme you just look at
the polynomials by hand like right yeah
yeah so that's that's a great question
so this is i mean really really what
ends up happening is that these these
these problems that that were given come
from practice and you know with that
example with that serial link robot we
actually had those cross product terms
and those dot product terms so
i mean really it's it's almost always at
least with with these problems that come
from practice these structures given to
us i mean these were just examples that
i
constructed and we actually knew that
they you know did the computations and
knew that they're going to have a
deficient uh bkk root count but
yeah that's you know if you're if you
have something that's expanded all the
way out how would you know what's the
what what's a good choice for the
replacement scheme there's
very difficult
did you have a yeah
it's very stupid but
so
you had the system with some structure
so the replacement is for me the same
thing just keeping your structure but
putting generic efficiency what you have
so you can't have a start system any of
those
what what's new that you are adding to
this like
i don't know how to say you can use the
search this system any system with this
structure but generic conditions what's
the difference with what you're doing
so with so you're saying that you have
your generic system so you have your
fixed replacement scheme and then you
have your
yeah yeah yeah
all right so it's a stupid question but
i say
if you just you have coefficients one
minus five two yeah yeah instead of
those you put a b c d generic you put in
this structure generic coefficients
what's the difference
sure so if you would go ahead and um
choose yeah if you let these guys be all
yeah yeah so so if you let these guys be
all generic right now then
i mean
yeah that's i mean that's exactly what
this replacement scheme is doing but the
current methods and these like say how
polyhedral methods are implemented and
uh
uh these actually will expand out
everything and then you'll actually end
up with the the the four extraneous pass
so
even if you even if we go ahead and
choose this right now as such letting
these be all generic
we'll still end up with those extra
extraneous paths with the current not if
you start in one of those the question
that maybe for one of those is not easy
to find the solutions but i mean if you
choose any generic coefficients with
this structure and you start with one of
those you have the right number of paths
yep yes
yes precisely the same as solving this
yes that's yeah that's exactly it yeah
that's that's that's precisely what
you're saying correct
yeah
wait
how do you know that the new system has
a smaller network in other words how do
you know that the generalized mix volume
is always smaller than this volume uh
and that that one this slide here with
this
this this guy or
with the trivial replacement because
we're doing a randomization here so then
all that all that we're saying is by
some bertini randomization theorem we
might increase the number of solutions
so what ends up happening is that the uh
the number of solutions that we have
here right
with with this guy with this trivial
replacement might might increase it
whenever we generalize
these particular coefficients with this
fixed scheme so the in in our system
that we had originally we might have
even more special coefficients and
they may not all be generic i mean that
was a great example with this this
example too here is that in this
particular replacement we actually don't
have um
if we go ahead and choose everything to
be generic now right what ends up
happening is that we we still didn't get
that additional structure with these
guys here and that wasn't included in
our replacement scheme so that was why
we had that make the generalized mix
volume of 30 but still had our root
count of 24.
so in that transparency these are these
were not minuses can you show that back
again yeah there's something wrong
if i generalize
i thought it was minus no where here
oh my god it's a dash yeah
these are these are two cases right oh
this is this is a dash not a minus yeah
there yeah i'm sorry this is this is a
dash it should be like dash dash or
something like to indicate not being uh
so you are not certain that always the
gmv will be smaller than the energy of
the original right this here yeah yeah
yeah yeah precisely yeah confusing
i
mean what's the theorem here and what's
the geometry that's behind it i mean i
saw it i mean i'm sorry i saw some
examples and i don't know what
journalized mixed volume is and i don't
know what okay
the mixed volume of this of this
replacement system what's the geometry
behind right so the geometry is we're
fixing this guy we're with specific and
special coefficients what's what's
happening here i mean i see some
algorithms but what's happening okay
yeah so what's really happening is that
with this generalized mixed volume we're
really trying to keep a hold of that
additional structure that we had from
from before so what do you mean by
additional structure i mean there are a
number of statements here that are not
very clear
right so by additional structure some
type of sub-expression that occurs
repetitively in in the polynomial system
that's one example of some structure
you can assume you have a linear space
of polynomials
um then you get the mixed volume
you can restrict your roots to a certain
algebraic variety
by keeping linear space of functions
then you get the graphic
bound
but you may also think that your
polynomials lay on a variety
and then there will be a generic number
of roots and i think this is
i mean that's that's the idea right is
that the what's happening is that we're
we're fixing this guy and after we fix
this we let this guy be generic and the
whole point is that the number of
isolated solutions that we end up here
at the end of the day for this
particular solution we haven't let these
guys be all generic we're fixing these
to some specialized space right so we
have some fixed
algebraic variety that we're setting
this guy to be and then after that we're
hitting it with some other space
and this other space in a sense is this
generic space so what happens when he is
likely i think because i've done it also
in some examples is that you remove
roots at torque infinity
yes so the reason that your mixed volume
is not equal to the true number of roots
is that you have roots authority
infinity right but in these service
examples there's an athletic
transformation which reduces it to
something which has the correct mixed
volume so you somehow looking at the
monomials in a different way but i don't
know what you're doing
why why why one instead of x one plus
one what happens is that some roots at
our infinity will not show up
another operation is linear and you have
a one to one so
um
maurice
just a good comment
it would be very nice to see some
settings where you can actually find
this this transformation in polynomial
time i mean do you think maybe in a
certain fixed number of variables or in
certain restricted settings you can
actually get some kind of a solid
theorem in this direction
yeah where you can actually say that
this is this replacement and then
actually be able to get this in other
words for these kinds of guys i can find
the replacement reasonably fast so
something like that
yeah this is related to what luke had
sort of asked initially is how do we you
know if you're given something and it's
all expanded out how do you even know
what a good replacement choice is
already kind of subtle so in one
variable there's actually some
interesting work on ship to spar stuff
so if you have a polynomial and it looks
really really big uh you can actually
ask okay is it a shifted sparse
polynomial is it a parse is a sparse
polynomial infected with a shift and
there's actually algorithms for doing
that in polynomial time oh really okay i
did not know this
in various other people and so and then
it's also reminiscent of other words
this is work by philippe de castro so if
you have a polynomial and you want to
know if it's composition of other
polynomials then there's actually a way
to find what the composition was in
polynomial time i think we're fine at
fields but it seems like what you're
trying to do is do this in more
variables and that seems rather hard so
the first thing to do would be to find
some nice setting where you can do
things in polynomial time and see when
can you do this quickly yeah i'd like to
talk to you more about that and get
those references and
haven't really
come across a lot of this in the
literature so
thanks
all right let's thank